being a referee is a very empowering job
because i get to yell at people and they
have to listen to me it's kind of nice
to be able to get in people's faces but
ultimately our number one job is helping
the wrestlers tell a story and if i'm
getting in a wrestler's face we probably
talked about it ahead of time
[Music]
my name is brittany albert but most
people probably know me as aubry edwards
referee for all elite wrestling
i grew up in northern california
i was a classical ballet dancer since i
was nine years old and ever since i was
little i wanted to make video games
so i moved up to seattle went to a
school called the japan institute of
technology got my four-year bachelor's
in computer science
my biggest claim to fame is i was a
project lead on scribblenauts which was
on nintendo ds so we were we launched
title i worked on that game for about
six and a half years various different
iterations of it
most people end up watching wrestling as
a kid and that's not something i did my
dad said it was stupid and that it's
fake and you shouldn't watch it
but i first watched wrestling
wrestlemania 27
a couple friends of mine had a party and
i literally have no idea what's going on
i'm like this is this is okay i guess
and that was the moment that got my
husband back into it he was a fan when
he was younger so
he started watching it and one day i
come home from work and he says hey you
got to watch this thing that happened
and it was june about 10 years ago where
cm punk does his famous python promo and
from that moment i was hooked and i
think part of that is because i had been
a ballet dancer for so long i
immediately saw the performance aspect
of it wrestling is really the only form
of entertainment that has the
relationship with the audience it does
the crowd is interacting the crowd is
booing the bad guys and cheering the
good guys and performers have the
opportunity to respond to that and that
doesn't happen anywhere else so it was
absolutely fascinating and i fell in
love with it
i
was
been working on games professionally for
you know near 10 years
and i was looking at retiring from
ballet my body was destroyed mental
health reasons i just needed to step
away
and after leaving that i got super
depressed because performing turns out
was a very big
form of how i coped with a lot of
emotion so i needed something new and
someone came to me and said hey we have
this indie wrestling show that i was a
fan of and i attended every week
we think you should be a referee and i
said why would i want to do that that
sounds so silly like all they do is yell
at people whatever
so i tried it i was terrible i tried it
again i was a little bit better and a
month and a half later i did my first
show
two years later i'm here
a professional wrestling referee is a
very unique role in that a lot of people
think we're just someone who officiates
and enforces rules when in actuality we
have
what seems like 12 jobs in a given
moment
yes we're enforcing rules but the rules
are there to service the story we're
also in charge of helping the production
of a television show we're live on tv
for two hours we got to be off the air
at 9 59 59 and part of that is me
communicating
where we are in the show based on the
times i'm getting from the back my ear
piece to the wrestler so they can adjust
accordingly and we can stick to the
confines of what we're given to tell
that story i really like the punctuality
of we have to be on the air at eight and
we have to be off the air then so for me
it's just a different format of instead
of following the schedule in a
spreadsheet you're following a schedule
based on what tony tells you
day of television i wake up i hit the
gym i don't think a lot of people
understand how in shape you have to be
as a referee hangman adam paige and
brian danielson go an hour but i don't
think people realize that paul turner
wasn't there for an hour as well and
that's a lot to ask of a referee because
you're reacting constantly to everybody
and every movement that's happening i'll
end up hitting the venue pretty early i
get the makeup chair first because
there's a lot of girls that day and i
know i'm on the show and i just want to
get in and get out i do a lot of just
trying to communicate
to people backstage as the wrestlers are
figuring things out we're meeting up
with them talking about finishes talking
about specific spots different camera
angles we're working with the coaches to
figure out what are the story elements
we want to see it's just a lot of
throwing a bunch of things at the wall
and hoping it all sort of works out a
single day we're filming a two-hour
episode of live television but i mean
it's a 12 to 13 hour day for us so today
is the debut of dynamite on tbs and
one of the things that i'm personally
excited about i even did my nails to
match it uh is the tbs championship so
this has been a tournament we've had
with the women's division and i am very
honored to be the person that will be
roughing that match refining the match
itself is not terrifying it's the act of
okay i have this belt i show it to
people now i need to make sure it's not
held upside down
so that's that little panic attack that
every ref has
it would still look good upside down
it's a very interesting thing
being a woman in this role because at
the same time i don't want to be seen as
a woman in this role but i also know
what it means to be in the prominent
position i am coming from another male
dominated industry like video games it's
something that's sort of been on my mind
my entire adult life that there's not a
lot of women and what we're doing is
super important for representation's
sake and giving other women
opportunities aew is a very interesting
place because to me i don't think about
it like i'm just there yelling at dudes
who play fighting their underwear i'm
not really thinking about like
you know what it means for me to be my
gender in this role but
hearing the responses from
parents especially on twitter saying
like
my kids are watching you and saying i
want to be her when i grow up and that's
just really really
like
i had no idea right but now i see the
impact that i'm having in wrestling and
that's really great
something like being the first woman to
ref a main event title match at
pay-per-view
we didn't do that so we could check the
box like both jericho and hangman asked
me to do that match because they wanted
me specifically to do it something about
her just stood out that she
had kind of star quality
which isn't super important for a ref
but it is to me i thought she was the
best person for the job and i thought
combining that with the fact that it's
the first time ever using a female in
this high profile position would be a
really cool kind of a one-two punch
forward thinking type of an idea because
in the past you would never
consider having a woman referee a guy's
match why i don't know
but i thought it was time to change that
in 2019
and that's what we did
regardless of what it is you're doing
whether it's a male-dominated feel or
not that doing the best job that you
possibly can
is the absolute most important thing the
fact that i'm a woman is just extra
bonus
you